okay
just hello hi it's good to see you all
um happy to be with here here with you
today um I am feeling a little scared
and sad today as I imagine a lot of you
are um and I think it's okay for us to
sit in that and grieve if you need to um
to be honest I don't have much to say
that can fix that um all I can say is
that growing up in the South and growing
up in the
church the grief that I feel right now
felt wrong and felt sinful and what a
gift it is that I no longer have to
grieve Alone um what a gift it is to be
here with all of you um this community
has been a gift to me to remind me that
I'm not interpreting God all wrong um
God really does love and welcome all
people and that the empathy we share for
each other and for marginalized
communities is not a thorn in our flesh
but is a reflection of all that is good
and
holy um to my lgbtq siblings um fellow
assault victims black and brown siblings
or anyone else who's feeling scared or
sad today even in the south and even in
the church you're not alone you're seen
and you are loved for every inch of who
you
are so um these candles are a sign of
the presence of Christ Among Us fully
Divine and fully human and now we exit
the kingdom of noise hurry and
productivity and we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and simplicity a
Sacred Space a place for prayer PR
worship and adoration a place to behold
Christ revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you and to mend your heart
may we all come
home thanks
[Music]
Rachel I love what she said
um and the reminder that there is space
for each one of us and what we all carry
into this space is welcome and let's
stand together and sing tonight and lift
our voices as as the body of Christ who
is dearly loved and seen and welcomed
[Music]
God I love to you I won't be
overwhelmed give me
Vis to see things like you do God I love
to you you're where my help comes
from give me
wisdom you know just what to do
[Music]
[Applause]
you God I look to
you I won't be
overwhelmed give me
[Music]
Vision to see things like you do God I
look to you you're where my help comes
from give me
wi you know just what to do and I will
love you Lord my
[Music]
strength I will love you Lord my
shield and I will love you
Lord my rock forever all my days I will
love you
[Music]
guys God I love to
you I won't be overwhelm
give me
[Music]
Vision to see things like you do God I
look to you you're where my help comes
from give me
[Music]
wisdom you know just what to do and I
will love you Lord my
strength I will love you Lord my
shield and I will love you Lord my rock
forever all my days I will
[Music]
love sing
Hallelujah god
reigns
hallelu
hallelujah our god raign forever all my
days
hallelujah sing Hallelujah
God
[Music]
hallelu
God
[Applause]
[Music]
hallelujah forever all my days
hallelujah sing I will love you and I
will love you
Lord my
strength I will love you Lord my
sh I will love
you
rock forever all my days I will
love you guys
yes God we love
you kiddos you guys are dismissed to go
to your
classrooms your teachers will be over by
the doors to meet you
[Music]
there thank you so much kids ministry
team we appreciate you guys hope it's a
great
night let's transition into the prayers
of the people and if you'll follow along
with the parts that are in red on the
screen with us and uh feel free to speak
out what you're carrying into this space
and lift it up before God as a community
we treasure this time where um we can be
honest about the things that we're
caring the things that are on our hearts
um so would you guys follow along please
with this
prayer Jesus for the city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
all who live in them we pray to
you for the Good Earth you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it we pray to you for the old and the
sick for the Widow and orphan for the
injured and suffering we pray to you for
the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for those who are
scared for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence
amen we're going to learn a new song
together tonight um it's called faith
more precious than gold and it's a song
that has just been kind of like my go-to
these last several months um I love when
I find worship music that feels honest
and I don't know how many of you guys
grew up in the church and maybe have
felt the awkwardness of singing along to
something that you didn't totally know
you believed or resonated with um at
times um so it's it's been kind of a
challenge especially in this community
um in the role that I'm in I want to
find music that resonates with us as
true as things that we can sink into and
root ourselves in truths that we can
Proclaim together and feel good about
singing and this one for me has been
very true lately there is
grief there is pain and together in this
space we can hold that before God and
trust that he is enough that he is here
with us that he is going to see us
through and not as a platitude not as a
good Christian kid who's like there's
always hope but a deep seated sense of
belief that God is the light and he is
our Rock and he is our
strength so want to read this passage
really quickly out of Isaiah
45 says this is what the Lord says to
his
anointed to those whose right hand I
take hold of to subdue Nations before
him and to strip Kings of their honor to
open doors before him so that Gates will
not be shut I will go before you I will
level the mountain
I'll break down Gates of bronze and cut
through bars of iron I will give you
Treasures of Darkness riches stored in
secret places so that you may know that
I am the Lord I am the god of Jacob who
summons You by name for the sake of
Jacob my servant of Israel My Chosen I
summon you by name and I bestow on you
titles of Honor even though you did not
acknowledge me
[Music]
I hope that tonight as we sing these
words together that we can remember that
God is a god of
connection he is always breaking down
barriers between us and calling us
towards
connection towards
invitation and sometimes we show up and
we are roaring with praise and sometimes
we show up and we are barely a whisper
of grief or pain or or struggle but we
all have a place at his table there is a
seat for each one of us tonight so let's
sing this song along as you kind of
catch on if you can lift your voice with
us or hold on to those words in our
heart let's reach for connection with
our maker with our
creator and with each
other we have suffered all kinds of
grief tasted the bitter cup of
defeat out of the bitter come something
sweet our faith more precious than
gold we have been tested by so many
fires burned in the heat of what our
hope
requires find us here singing in a
foolish choir our faith more preious
than gold our faith our faith more
precious than
gold though we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
sing and we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in everything
[Music]
is sing there is a
secret there is a secret we can only
know walking through places we don't
want to
go cuz in the dark we learn the song
of hope our faith more precious than
gold our faith more precious than gold
though we don't see
you though we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
see we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in every
Jesus Jesus in
everything tears on the alar from all we
lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe a
whisper maybe a roar this is the sound
of those who love you this is the sound
this is the sound of those who love you
that tears tears on the altar from all
we lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe a
whisper maybe a roar this is the sound
of those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those who love you though we
don't
see though we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
see we've got to reason to trust
you Jesus in
everything no we don't though we don't
see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
s we've got a reason to trust
Jesus in Everything Jesus in
Everything Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
in Jesus in
everything Tears On The
Altar from all we've
lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe you
whisper maybe you roar this is the sound
of those who love let's sing that again
Tears On The Altar Tears On The Altar
from all we
lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe a
whisper maybe a roar this is the sound
of those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those who love you this is the
sound
this is the sound of those who love
you this is the sound of those who love
you Lord tears on the
altar of what we've lost following you
no matter what it
C maybe a
whisper maybe a ro this is the sound of
those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those who love you Lord this is
the sound of those who love you Lord
this is the sound of those who
[Music]
love yes
God God we lift our voice
es God hear the song of our heart
tonight be with
[Music]
us and I've carried a
birden for too long on my
own and I wasn't
created to car it
[Music]
alone I hear your
invitation to let it all
go I see it now I'm laying it down and I
know that I need you I run to the father
falling to Grace I'm done with the
hiding no reason to wait my heart needs
a suron my soul needs a friend so I run
to the father again and again and again
and
again
oh oh
[Music]
you saw my
condition had a plan from the
start your son for
Redemption the price for my
heart and I don't have a
Conex for that kind of love Ador
understand I can't
comprehend all I know is I need you I
run to the father I fall it Grace I'm
done with the highing no reason to wait
my heart needs a suron my soul needs a
friend so I run to the father again and
again and again again and
again
W
oh
oh again and
again
[Music]
wo
oh my heart is been in your sides long
before my first breath death running
into your arms is running to life from
Death I feel this Rush deep in my chest
his Mercy is
calling out just as I am you pulled me
in and I know I need you
now I run to the father I fall into
Grace I'm done with the heart and reason
away my heart needs a Sur my soul needs
a f so I run to the father again and
again I run to the father I fall into
Grace I'm done with the hiding no reason
to wait my heart needs a se My Soul
found a friend so are run to the father
again and again and again and
[Music]
again
oh
oh again
again
oh oh
[Music]
oh run to the father fall into Grace I'm
done with the hiding no reason to wait
my heart found to sering my soul found a
friend so I run to the father again and
again and again and again
[Music]
God we run to you
tonight with all of our different
stories all of our different backgrounds
and
beliefs and positions God we come to
you our maker and
Creator the one who hemmed Us in before
and behind
[Music]
God would you fashion us after your
heart would you make us a people of
compassion a people of justice and
righteousness a people of patience in a
world of
hurry a people of faith in a world of
fear
[Music]
God would you be our inner
fortitude our strong
Mountain our shelter and our
[Music]
Fortress thank you for who you
are thank you God that we get to be your
[Music]
children it's in your name Jesus that we
pray all these
things
amen would you guys turn and say hello
to the people around you tonight
well Grace and
peace it is good to be with you all
really really good uh my name is Brett
and the pastor here and um yeah just
good to be together good to welcome you
into this space and uh as always that
includes those joining us online love
youall Lots you're not forgotten and uh
don't forget to get your communion
elements for at the end and uh anyone
here tonight who is new uh thanks for
being Among Us I know it just it can be
a lot take a lot of courage courage to
come into this space for the first time
so yeah thank you for being here um
Rachel's going to talk about this more
at the very end of the service but I I
want to mention next week is uh we're
celebrating the table's fifth
anniversary which is pretty dang cool um
yeah let's give it
up so um yeah it is it's special it's
Unique you know it's like hey we're here
we're still
here can't believe it and I'll actually
talk to some about Co in this message
and so you know we we've been through
some hard times you know and uh but
we're here and God's faithful and
Christ's love just keeps just keeps uh
what is it it's it's sustaining us and
it's like flowing out of us you know to
others and it's it's a good work that
God's doing and uh and the spirit's
doing it through through all of you you
know and it's it's a beautiful thing to
to witness uh as your pastor I'm really
yeah I'm grateful for this community to
to be with you all to stand alongside
you so the title of my message uh
tonight is the hero's
journey and I actually wrote this
message uh a few weeks back but uh it
still it still feels timely still feels
relevant which I'm grateful for uh it's
always stressful in the pastor has to
rewrite their message for this Sunday so
um so I don't think I have to do that um
but yeah I hope it hope it speaks and
resonates with you so I want to start
here it was the uh the writer Joseph
Campbell um in his book The Hero with a
thousand faces I think he was um one of
the first people to kind of name this
there's a kind of narrative Arc uh to
many of the stories um that we love uh
across like time across cultures even
across religious
traditions and they they follow this Arc
and he called it the hero's journey um
but it's it's kind of a a story arc that
you know you will definitely recognize
it let's just put it that way you know
so the the the narrative it tends to
begin with something like you have an
ordinary person sometimes they're
extraordinary but usually the story is
better if they're ordinary you know
someone anyone can relate to this person
you know the ordinary person and then
someone comes to them with a call with
an
invitation to you know it can vary to an
adventure to go on a journey to fight a
great battle to you know whatever kind
of to to um to kind of receive this call
now normally um they reject it they
reject the call at least initially like
and if it's a young you know kiddo they
might like go away and hide you know
like I can't I'm not possibly you know
big enough to do that you know or if
they're an older person they might be
like get off my
lawn you know I retired from the
military years ago you know or you know
I don't coach anymore and of course if
you're like watching the movie or
reading the book you know like oh
they're going to coach again you know
it's like yeah okay so so but initially
they reject the call you know now why
because there's a lot of fear you know
it's like usually the the call the
invitation um it scares the Jesus out of
you you know so just like oh no I don't
want to do that but inevitably you know
they're like okay yes this is what I
need to do right so there's kind of the
the call rejection of the call and then
kind of the acceptance of the call and
then we it would be nice if from there
is always onward and upward and they
just you know go from success to success
but of course that's not a good story
and it's not real life either so from
there you go into this kind of it's
called different things could be kind of
like the Wilderness the desert uh a
trial an ordeal you know it's it's time
of
testing um they come through that
there's a season then of like maturity
kind of breakthrough leading to Victory
and then a return to ordinary right the
in any story there's almost always a
moment where like they go back back home
or you know wherever they came from and
then what do they realize though it's
like they're back where they began and
yet they're not right who's changed like
they've changed so
dramatically so right you can kind of
see then this this sort of narrative Arc
and um the thing is like we
love watching reading about engaging
stories of the hero's journey I know
this because of like the industries that
are built around this you know like just
bill we spend billions of dollars a year
Watching uh partaking and engaging with
these kinds of
stories and uh and you can see it all
over the place right from I mean coming
to scripture you can think of the story
even of Jesus sort of follows something
like the hero's journey uh to say Luke
Skywalker to odys
um to uh oh Black Widow like almost any
like of the all the Marvel movie like
all the superhero you it's almost always
a hero's journey kind of narrative Arc
you know and uh and we love this however
the trick is admittedly it is much more
comfortable to watch others partake in
their hero's
journey then it is to do
what to engage our own
right like that that's the TR we will
spend billions like yes good for them so
inspiring love it for them you know uh a
little more challenging when we suddenly
find ourself in the middle of our own
little hero's journey but but here's the
truth I believe all of us are invited by
God into a heroic journey and by that I
don't necessarily mean you know to to
become so successful and famous and I
don't I'm not talking about that I I
simply mean um in the sense of to
become much more than we ever believed
or thought we could become like that's a
heroic journey to grow to be stretched
beyond our capacity what we feel like oh
I can't do that I can't face that I
can't take that
like and and yet to face into
that to to go into the desert to go into
that trial and come through the process
like oh it's a powerful powerful thing
so our um our scripture today charts a
kind of hero's journey uh for a woman
named
Naomi it's kind of interesting that the
book it's so the book where this is told
in scripture is the Book of Ruth um I
wonder if it should have been the book
of Naomi because really the so much of
the The Arc is is really about uh Naomi
so that we pick up the story there in
Ruth 1:
1-2 it says in the days when the judges
ruled there was a famine in the land so
a man from Bethlehem in Judah together
with his wife and two sons went to live
for a while in the country of Moab the
man's name was IMC his wife's name was
Naomi the names of his two sons were
Malone and kilan they were ephrathites
from Bethlehem Judah and they went to
Moab and and they lived there so right
off the bat you can kind of already see
the beginning of the hero's journey
taking place right like you've got um
Naomi starts off in
Bethlehem and mentioning all of her
family like she's got a good life in
Bethlehem you know wife two kids like
this is It's a good it's a good thing
she's got going in Bethlehem in fact um
the very name Naomi in Hebrew it means
uh Pleasant
isn't that perfect like just Pleasant
like that's Naomi's got a just a good
life a pleasant life there in
Bethlehem and was there ever a moment
like in your own life where you maybe
wasn't even the moment you didn't like
realize it but looking back you say ah
Pleasant you know like the like we even
have the language for this like the good
old days you know or whatever like oh
that was such a good time like a sweet
time like oh I just I love those times
you know we we can all kind of relate to
this this um having some season where it
was like things are working don't you
love it when things are working it's
like yes you know it's
working suddenly though a famine strikes
the
land isn't this how it always goes you
finally get your stuff together and then
it all hits the fan it's all like if
you're have these moments where things
are going well at least the older you
get it's almost like the more suspicious
you get of that have you found that I
found this like like uhoh things are
going too well you know it's like we're
I don't know maybe that's like an INR 6
thing I sound like an INR 6 uh but we
can relate to this you know and suddenly
this is where Naomi is right she she
finds her her family uh suddenly as
immigrants in a the foreign land of
Moab now of course Moab is hard but
things are about to get much more
difficult we pick up the story in verse
three now ALC Naomi's husband
died she was left with her two sons they
married moabit women one named orpa the
other Ruth after they had lived there
about 10 years
both Mone and Killian
also
died Naomi was left without her two sons
and her husband imagine that moment for
her like the the group grief of like her
whole world her whole world it's like
gone
now it begins she thought Moab was it
you know but I wonder if Moab was like I
I but I still kind of got that often you
can be kind of alerted to a hero's
journey type thing going on in a story
that you're partic you know reading or
something or even in your own life by
the question do I feel like I kind of
like I kind of kind of got this or do I
suddenly not got this that's like when
when you don't have it that's when
you're really being invited
into uh like a real heroic
journey I think of uh Simba driven from
the pro lands you know I think of uh
Rocky and all those training
montages sweating and grunting and
swearing or whatever I think of uh Moana
braving the high seas think of Jesus
heading out to the desert to be
tempted think of Abraham leaving his
hometown to go to a he knows not of I
think of the children of Israel leaving
Egypt heading out to the
Wilderness see at some point we get
initiated into this journey and suddenly
we find find ourselves in the desert in
the trial in this great ordeal stretched
beyond what we feel we can
bear whether it's the child on drugs
the cancer divorce bankruptcy like
whatever it
is we we just get pushed beyond what we
can take I look uh
I alluded to this earlier I looked back
on the years of covid uh that was a
desert season really kind of culturally
but for us at the table it was a kind of
season of trial and uh and for me
personally it was it was hard like we so
we launched the table in um well you
know it was five years five years ago so
uh right there November
2019 and so we had you know a few months
few months and it was like y'all you
wouldn't believe how good it was going
for those who weren't here it was y man
we just launched off you I mean the
there's something to about a new thing
and the energy and the excitement and
you know I mean it's like like it's good
talk about Pleasant it was pleasant it
was awesome and just passionate you know
yeah and then within a few months of
course the world shuts down she's
[Music]
like oh my God I was like what is going
on like this is this is bad I hly if I'm
really truthful some of what was going
through my head was we had had people
when we launched the table you know who
didn't support kind of what we were
doing and even you know said like this
is uh this is God's not going to bless
this you know that kind of thing and it
wasn't so much that I thought oh this is
a sign oh it's the Lord sent Co for the
T you know I don't think that it wasn't
that it was more like I wondered how
others might how like those folks might
see you know what I mean like
uh and uh it was hard season like we
lost a lot of people I mean many
churches I know churches that shut down
during that um like permanently um so
hard but we I I will remember a moment
probably maybe at least for me one of
the lower moments um it's funny looking
back on it as a lot of suffering is you
know you can laugh about it later need
five years and then you can laugh you
know um and we had this some of you God
blessed you were here for this we had a
uh a Christmas Eve service outside
oh my gosh y'all worst Christmas Eve
service ever so I mean at that point it'
been like nine months or so you know or
whatever so we um we wanted to try to
get the gang back together but we
couldn't do inside so we tried it
outside and you know sometimes you try
things and it just doesn't work like it
was just the worst Texas weather like
the cold front blowing in like
gray I mean it was it was sad and I came
away from that service and I was kind of
like
Merry Christmas you know
like man this is tough like
God we might be going down you
know yeah I felt like I was
failing see at some point at some point
we all find ourselves in the desert
place of trial testing training loss
formation and that's where Naomi is
right now death of her husband her two
sons now she's facing a life of almost
certain poverty and utter
destitution but she gets word that the
famine Has Lifted in Bethlehem so Naomi
decides to return
home alone she tells her two
daughter-in-laws
look I've got nothing for you like go
home your your your husbands my sweet
sons are dead like return to Moab try to
rebuild your life don't don't follow me
like I'm not worth following and
orpa argues with her but but eventually
agrees to leave uh but it's Ruth who
says this verse 16 don't urge me to
leave you or to turn back from you
where you go I will go and where you
stay I will stay your people will be my
people and your God my God where you die
I will die and there I will be buried
may the Lord deal with me be it ever so
severely if even death separates you and
me see Naomi thought God had abandon her
she says as much to some friends I think
it's in chapter
3 but actually
what you didn't realize was that God was
showing up in Ruth in fact the Hebrew
root word for the name Ruth is reut
which means
friend Ruth the
friend you see when we are in the
desert God's grace often arrives in the
guise of a faithful
friend God God's grace arrives in the
friend so in your season of bitterness
and
loss
ask who's my Ruth right
now or if you are young can reverse it
and ask who is my Naomi right now or you
can generalize it who are my people
right now who is God bringing my way
right the point being don't try and make
the hero's journey alone that would be
like the most American thing ever and
foolish right this is this is just not
how people make a hero's journey every
Anna needs an Olaf can I get an name
in every Naomi needs a Ruth and every
Ruth a Naomi so the two women they head
back to Bethlehem
and finally after
years of grief and
pain the Breakthrough
happens so they live in this intensely
like patriarchal culture so Ruth and
Naomi like they can't um there's no just
let's just go out and get jobs you know
like it's not that kind of situation so
they know one of us has to get married
and Naomi was a realist about this she's
like Ruth you're our best bet girl so if
you know the story there's like a whole
there's like a whole thing um Ruth ends
up meeting a man uh named Boaz she likes
him he likes her she definitely like
seduces him and stuff and it's it's all
very sweet um so Ruth ends up
um uh well yeah meeting this guy and
eventually um they decide to marry and
so this takes us um to the end of the
story in chapter 4 beginning in verse 13
so Boaz took Ruth and she became his
wife when he made love to her the Lord
enabled her to conceive and she gave
birth to a son the women said to Naomi
praise be to the Lord who this day has
not left you without a guardian Redeemer
may he become famous throughout Israel
he will renew your life and sustain you
in your old age for your daughter-in-law
who loves you and who is better to you
than seven sons has given him
birth now here's verse 16 then what does
Naomi do then Naomi took the
child in her
arms and
cared for
him what a
moment Ian what do you think that moment
was like for her
like this is the Breakthrough the
victory see when you're in the desert
you feel like it's desert forever for me
this is just my lot in life it's not
true it's not true it's not
forever when I think of Naomi and why it
was so good I don't think it was in
spite of her suffering in spite of her
bravery in her journey I think it was
because of it see she has wrestled with
God and with life and has
prevailed friends this is what life is
about it's this kind of wrestling it's
about going on a journey facing the
Wilderness and coming coming out
Victorious
deepened
matured
tested
transfigured don't we want to be able to
say at the end of our days I didn't run
away that's a word for someone I didn't
run
away I faced
it I faced it I embraced it and God
brought me
through now you might be wondering why
do we have to go on these
Journeys why does this matter can I just
opt out without consequences the story
comes to a close with these words
chapter 4: 16 and 17 then Naomi took the
child in her arms and cared for him the
women living there said Naomi has a son
and they named him obid he was the
father of Jesse the father of
David in other words Naomi and Ruth did
not know it but their whole story turned
out to be part of an origin story Naomi
the Widow Ruth The Foreigner turned out
to be Central to The Narrative of the
most famous King and Israelite light
history and so I wonder whose origin
story are you playing a part in again I
don't mean like what Rich famous
successful World changer are you I don't
I don't mean that I I I just mean like
our decision your decision for or
against the journey God's inviting you
into it
matters it it it even has kind of Ripple
relational ripple effect effect down
through history no
pressure but I mean but on the one like
I could see us wanting to reject that
you know and yet this is precisely what
makes life
meaningful because yeah it matters like
the downside is oh no it matters you
know what I mean but that's the that's
the price you pay for hey good news it
matters it matters who you are matters
how you walk your journey matters who
you walk it with matters your heart
posture within that it all matters
saying yes to this inner call of God
saying yes to growth in maturity is what
we're invited into so in this
season I encourage you to engage
whatever that looks like for you engage
your friends engage your marriage engage
your co-workers engage your family
engage even this church
Community because it seems that our
Destinies have become
intertwined so let's embrace the
challenge let's don't run
away let's Don't Panic or get
selfish let's show up for god let's show
up for one another and
trust that though it may feel like we
are freef falling we are as Maggie Ross
says free falling into the very love of
God in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so on the
night that Jesus was
betrayed he uh he had one final meal
with his disciples and at that meal he
held a loaf of bread and then he broke
it and he said take it this is my body
it's broken for you and then he held up
a cup of wine and he said this is my
blood it's shed for you whenever you eat
this bread whenever you drink this cup
remember me so as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in the
body of Christ in the bread the blood of
Christ in the wine may it be a
reentering moment may it be a
regrounding moment and and perhaps a
moment where if you're up for it we
where you you start to say Yes again to
the call that God has for you so the way
we'll participate tonight is we'll just
start here at the front and we'll just
form one line and we'll just kind of
work our way row by row um to the back
we practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then you are free to
do that regardless of your exact like
theology or denominational affiliation
um you're you're welcome to to
participate having said that there's no
pressure to if you're in a place where
you don't want to that's fine as well uh
you should know the red is wine the
white is grape juice and then finally
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like some folks like to
come here and kneel um others just like
to take immediately or return to your
seats but no one will lead you through
the exact moment of partaking so this is
the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so
come come you who have much faith
and you who have little you who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long you who have tried to
follow and you who have failed come come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
[Music]
you
I'm going to have Jesse close us out
with the song called someday
soon um I hope that it ministers to you
the way that it has ministered to me
tonight as we've played it together you
guys are welcome to just sit back taking
these words and let them be soul
food there is a shadow in the
hallway trying to frighten
you don't let the
darkness around
you you can make it through
don't you give up on the
[Music]
kingom think it's crashing in no it
ain't worth all the
worry they'll still let you
[Music]
in so
day soon these worries roll
[Music]
on
somay
soon in
[Music]
the sometimes the
weight of
decisions will try to be you don't let
the
shame tell you
something that you know ain't
true just cuz you
feel like a
stranger that don't mean you
are God I could use a reminder
of what forgiveness is
for some days soon these worries roll
on some days soon
[Music]
somay soon these worries Roll
Along some days
[Music]
soon sometimes the cold wind
blows sometimes the Ws run
[Music]
don't think the
batt over just cuz they say
[Music]
Amen sometimes the cold
wind
blows sometimes the wols
rushing don't think the B
over just cuz they
say
am
somay soon these worries roll
[Music]
onay
soon in enough
[Music]
some days soon these were roll
on some days
[Music]
soon
somay
soon and
[Music]
dang that was really good
um thank you guys so much for being here
tonight um if you're new we'd love for
you to scan the QR code that's about to
be on the screen just to say thank you
for being here or answer any questions
you might have about our community about
this church um and you can fill out that
visitor
card um me meetups we can all use more
relational support and spiritual
connection um the way we do that at the
table is through our meetups if you're
not yet part of one you can scan the QR
code and find one that works for you um
generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship if you call the
table your church home um we invite you
to also scan that QR code to give
financially or visit the tabl tx.org um
like Brett said one week from today on
Sunday November 17th we're going to be
celebrating the table's 5th anniversary
uh with a special service where a few
folks will be sharing their stories and
we're going to have a chili cook off um
so please please please scan that QR
code again um and sign up to bring a
dish uh we would really appreciate that
all right um I'm going to send you into
your week with a benediction uh with a
blessing you can hold your hands out in
a posture to receive or just open your
heart to hear these words
you are a child of
God
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day so as you go
into your week ahead with it's yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are are worthy
and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come into contact with be
blessed and we'll see you next Sunday
thank
[Music]
you sometimes a c
wind the
[Music]
Ws don't think of
B over just cuz they
say
[Music]
Amen soon these worries roll
somay
[Music]
soon soon these worries
roll
somay
soon in
[Music]
some days
soon enough
[Music]